Mình đang sâu Iran có bố hình ảnh và video gì lại sáng mấy bài không ở lại hômift chính trạm của
Israel để phòng không nơi bắn hại gần thành phố Ispa Hanh.
Theo chuyến hiện của Sai Rhyp, Huawei mang theo rockhead và bong giãn đường, nhưng trước khi khai
hoa thì đã bị tư siet, cùng ngày có nơi Iran tuyên bố cùng đã bắn hả một tiêm
thích tảng hình A7 năm e, tại khu vực, Jamma đã bắt tình tới Iran, tuy nhiên là
tượng phòng về Israel i đẹp chỉ sắc nhận, có một ua về bị tên lượng phòng
Iran đánh chúng và rất súng lành tuy nữa ngày không gây thương bong hai sâu gì không tin?
E đẹp không đưa ra bình luận với thông tin chức Ep bà làm bị bắn hạ.
Mình xin chăm lỗi Huawei hiện đại có hả năng bay linh tục hơn bà mi giờ, măng theo
thi bị giò tháng và chính trang địa tự, đây là nơi tiled Iran có bộ bằng chứng chực quán
về việc bắn sơ mẹ bài quần sửa Israel.
Một số cua ra chung cua vật và các tổ chức cua tế đã lên tiếng bài tỏ quân hại,
kêu hội các bên kìm chế và chính nghiệp tình hình lau tháng thành xuống độc tàn sĩer.